how's it going mate
uh it's going pretty good actually i
watched this yesterday and had a lot of
fun with it roland definitely knows how
to make disaster porn
he certainly does he certainly does he's
he's the master of it you very rarely in
in your career get to work with true
experts in their field but when it comes
to disaster movies roland's top of that
tree and what a thrill to get to make
this movie with him uh i'm actually very
curious
what do you think it is about why
audiences love watching end of the world
tv shows and end of the world movies
i think it's it's it's because it
in a strange kind of way it gives them
an enhanced appreciation for real life
do not think of when you have a you have
a nightmare and you wake up and you're
and you're panicked but then suddenly
you realize that it wasn't real and
you're back in the real world and
there's that sense of relief to it
i think i think that there's something
to that you go to the theater you lock
into this concept that the world's
ending and you come out and everything's
still there so it's like it's like you
allow yourself to believe it just to get
the relief of it not being true
this is your first
uh big budget hollywood movie where
you're one of the leads i'm just curious
what was it like what was it like versus
what you expected going in
well coming out of something like game
of thrones which i was in for uh a
decade
the main difference between that and
this even though game of thrones was a
big budget thing
and and you know you know
world famous and all that kind of stuff
there were so many people in that the
cast was so huge we sort of divided up
the pressure
between us and nobody necessarily felt
too pressurized because we knew there
were so many other actors in it who
would take the reins from us at any
point but but being in this was such a
small central cast it's a big movie
small cast to it just myself patrick and
halle
uh in our little in our little
subplot for all that time just slightly
more pressure really just more pressure
the idea that i don't have i don't have
many other cast mates to hide behind i'm
sort of at the center of it with these
two other wonderful actors
and yeah i just felt more central to
things and that's a great honor and a
great privilege but a greater sense of
pressure comes from that too you know
there's more responsibility on your
shoulders to tell this story than there
ever ever has been before for me
uh i don't want to dwell on game of
thrones i just want to thank you for
your work on the show because i really
enjoyed it um but saying that i really
did want the night king to win it all i
i did i was i did i i was hoping we were
watching the end of a civilization not
able to work together and like the night
king was going to win and it's because
no one was willing to work together but
that was my secret dream
you know what that's that that's quite a
game of thronesy
ending isn't it
yeah they
say what you like about that show they
never they never
really took the easy route out and even
if some of the decisions they made were
controversial
i don't think that many people would
have
would have guessed what that was going
to be i don't think
yeah i i listen i they were constantly
always making me say holy f all the time
but anyway you know so thank you for
your work on that um but i'm so i am
curious does it ever get easier to
pretend to see something in the horizon
or is it sort of just like you know what
i mean because you're reacting to the
superstructure it's clearly not there
yeah it's something that you you know
when i talk to my pals about making this
kind of movie and they're not actors
it's the one thing about it that they
find most impressive you know reacting
to something that's not really there but
the thing is
you can do that really easy when you're
a kid
when you're five years old you can
imagine that you're in space when you're
just in your own front room and you can
just see your own couch your own couch
can become a spaceship really easily
when you're five so
it's not about learning how to do it
it's about
getting in touch with a child-like
imaginative side of yourself that's
laying sort of dormant really
getting rid of the self-consciousness
and the
sense of embarrassment about it and just
committing to it in a way that you very
rarely get the chance to do as a
grown-up something about something a
little bit of contacting a child-like
side of yourself makes it a lot easier
did you enjoy filming the anti-gravity
like the in-space anti-gravity stuff
were you like oh this is really
challenging
no it was it was uh
it was it was it was fine it was a
challenge but before we started shooting
it we had some consultations with actual
astronauts who gave us a key to it and
the main key to it that we had was
get this idea out of your head that your
legs are your main source of movement
around because when you're in space your
legs do absolutely nothing it's your
arms that guide you so you take the
focus of the movement away from the
lower half of your body and put it on
the on the on the top of your body on
your arms and shoulders and once you get
that into your mind it becomes quite
easy to sort of navigate your way around
even even a compact space like that i
have to ask so obviously this is one of
these films where the vfx really matter
and uh you know because it pulls it all
together so what was your reaction
watching the third act and seeing how
roland had built the superstructure and
everything that was going to be
happening
well that was tricky on the day because
you know we're talking about vfx stuff
that we've done before
i i mean we have no frame of reference
when it comes to the inside of the moon
like like roland completely got carte
blanche to design whatever he wanted as
far as the inside of the moon is
concerned so when we were trying to
imagine it looking out the window from a
vx vfx point of view we tried to imagine
what it might be like but
we were probably myself hallie and
patrick all imagining completely
different things but when we saw it we
realized
just just what an imagination it takes
to bring something like that
into re into life and and realize it and
and
and you know the design for the inside
of the moon was more than ever i could
have possibly imagined and that's why
roland was in charge and not me
um before i ran out of time which is
about to happen uh i'm really looking
forward to the three-body problem and
i'm just curious what what can you tease
about it and you know uh because it
sounds very cool it's very very cool
it's um
i i've finished the books uh just before
christmas and what i will say about it
is david and dan haven't um taken the
easy route out with this there are
elements of this the ambition of this
that makes even game of thrones look
like fairly safe ground it's
it's yeah the ambition the scope of it
the sheer size of it it's gonna it's
gonna break a whole new set of rules all
over again i think
is it like is it is it a three episode
series is it that i don't actually know
what the length and what it exactly is
it's um it's a it's it's a full series
it's it's a it's a full run of a
run of a netflix
uh series it's it's not a mini series
and it's not a movie it's um you know we
we we're getting information about it
all the time and you know the way the
way tv works you're never sure how long
you're going to go for you're never sure
what what what the scope of this is
going to be going forward but but
working on
this season of it it's it's a it's a
netflix series so it's like it's like
eight or ten episodes yeah
yeah um well listen i gotta stop there
i'm just gonna say i am really looking
forward to that and i really again thank
you for your work and great talking with
you great to talk to you too mate thanks
very much
you